if you like pizza and you enjoy pizza
and you eat pizza the like load it is
extremely high that you have seen our
pizza boxes my name is Gil Curran and I
make pizza boxes for a living
me roughly make 10 million boxes a week
as far as design is concerned it's very
particular you know picture of a pizza
box kind of like an album used to be it
kind of creates what the artist is all
about and that's what you know these
owners view their pizza boxes that I've
probably done over 10,000 designs this
is a Hawley original and it's everywhere
I see it in garbage pails I see it on
the side of the Parkway I see it at
friends houses when they get pizza the
fact that so many people literally
millions of people have seen my work and
don't know that it's me kind of makes me
chuckle to myself like I'm somehow
sneaking through life with this identity
that no one knows having started the
business from the beginning the one
thing about pizza it brings happiness to
everybody everyone loves pizza
[Music]